even if you're the most hardened of PTSD
ridden Dark Souls veterans there are
some things you should know before
diving headfirst into the frustration
and blood filled swimming pool that is
blood-borne there are three starting
weapons to choose from in blood-borne
each with its own strengths weaknesses
and quirks the saw cleaver is the most
balanced starting weapon hence why it's
appeared in most early blood-borne
footage it balances the quickness of a
lighter blade with the heft and power of
a heavier weapon making it the ideal
starter especially for those unfamiliar
with the soul genre the other two
weapons are more polarizing the threaded
cane is quick and nimble but it does
significantly less damage while the
hunter's axe is big and slow but it
dulls out the hurt most efficiently all
three weapons have the ability to extend
with l1 increasing their reach but
diminishing their speed slightly the
threaded cane extends into a chain whip
the saw cleaver unfolds and the axe
extends into a two-handed pole axe while
the saw cleaver seems to have the
shortest range while extended it's more
powerful than the threaded cane and the
extended axe prevents you from holding a
gun in your offhand this will keep you
from parrying and using ranged attacks
which can be a severe disadvantage in
certain fights pick the weapon that
caters best to your play style whether
you like it slow and lumbering or fast
and furious and speaking of fast and
furious fans coming from the souls games
are going to notice blood-borne is
dominant focus on aggressive and mobile
tactics over playing it safe you're not
going to be relying on a heavy shield or
casting fireballs here so get used to
dodging and rolling around like a Cirque
de Soleil Acrobat with a gun well locked
onto enemies hitting circle is going to
allow you to dodge in sidestep giving
you opportunities to navigate around
your opponent for a backstab or get out
of the way when they're trying to devour
you when you're not locked on dodging
will cause you to dive roll a fair bit
further allowing you to get the hell
away from a dangerous situation or move
behind a foe in one fell swoop it's also
worth noting that hitting your heavy
attack r2 at the same time you press
forward will trigger a heavy jump strike
allowing you to close the distance in
the same way a roll would but with all
the striking force of your strong attack
because you'll be pretty much shield
listen blood-borne armor is going to
take on additional importance in keeping
you alive before you engage the cleric
beast blood burns first boss you'll want
to either purchase the first set of
armor from the hunters dream when you've
saved up around 3,000 blood echoes or if
you're feeling thrifty and you've spent
all your money on vials the same set of
armor is available to be found deep
within the sewers don't be
- intimidated it may not be on route to
the cleric beast but the sewers are of a
fairly manageable difficulty and you'll
be handsomely rewarded for your bravery
with a hot news at armor don't be afraid
to drop your blood echoes on that same
set of armor though you most likely
won't beat the first boss in your first
attempt so you might as well invest
before you lose everything
say it with me now there are no souls in
blood-borne there are only blood echoes
hell I still call them Souls but here's
what you need to know about them whether
they're echoes or not
they virtually serve the exact same
purpose that souls did in the previous
Souls game allowing you to purchase
items and gear repair and fortify
weapons level up your skills and a
number of other things throughout the
game as you may have expected you'll
drop all your blood echoes upon death
but you'll have the chance to retrieve
them from the scene of your previous
death as long as you don't die on your
way there one change in blood-borne is
that enemies can pick up your
blood-stained forcing you to kill a
specific enemy to retrieve your
hard-earned echoes you can identify the
target enemy by their ethereal glowing
eyes which will help locate them but it
definitely won't help you kill them at
first you'll be wondering where to level
up as you explore the game's hub world
see that creepy sleeping doll in the
corner fight the Clara feast and either
win or die in the doll will awaken
allowing you to pour all your blood
echoes into levelling up I recommend you
do so lest you lose thirty thousand
echoes dying in a cave somewhere but
you'll need at least one insight in the
bank to cash in
finally a more general tip don't fear
grinding in blood-borne blood vials will
serve as your Estus flask replacement
here allowing you to regain health
fairly quickly and they're dropped
really frequently by even the easiest
enemies a failed boss fight is going to
drain your blood vials and quick silver
bullets in short order so don't be too
proud to get back on your feet by taking
on some manageable enemies to grind out
vials gear levels before walking back
into that nightmare fog for another bout
there's a lot more to say about
blood-borne but we really don't want to
spoil anything more of this excellent
game for you at least not in this video
so good luck out there oh and before you
go let me just introduce you to your new
best friend that you died screen you'll
be seeing a lot of him